some of the world's greatest cricket  players from suchin Kendall Kerr to  virod Kohli as the great religious  teacher Swami Vive come on what's said  I hope they now go and take a look at  the oranges or the oranges of the uh  investigation the beginnings of that  investigation the biggest lie ever  foistered upon the American people he  was awarded the bronze star and the  combat infantryman badge for his service  our army man the emperor it ran the  ramparts it took over the airports it  did everything it had to do we have to  keep our country gate prepared but it's  not I mean for some reason it's just not  great anymore if you care about law and  auto look Law and Order